yo estuve en la convención hace 4 años
nadie realmente comprendía el cambio
histórico que iba a ocurrir y todos
podemos sentir lo sabíamos que algo
estaba ocurriendo en movimiento se
estaba formando en la superficie los
hombres y las mujeres olvidados y pies
que no tenían voz en washington se
estaban preparando para levantarse
nuestro movimiento siguió el patrón de
tantos de otros que sigue que hubo antes
primero fuimos ignorados
después se rieron de nosotros después
lucharon contra nosotros y después
juntos ganamos a partir de ese momento
eeuu llegó primero eeuu comenzó a ganar
de nuevo comenzamos a ser respetados de
nuevo pero siempre existió un
contramovimiento y si son los radicales
demócratas dicen que este país es la
fuente de los problemas creen que el
único camino es borrar la historia y
acabar con el pasado
quieren destruir los monumentos de
nuestros padres quieren y respetar
nuestra bandera quieren quemar esta
bandera que representa el patriotismo y
el sueño estadounidense quieren y
respetar el himno arrodillándose
mientras que las fuerzas
arriesgan sus vidas para protegerla no
quieren el juramento o decir que somos
una nación bajo dios quieren
desfinanciar y respetar a la policía los
demócratas quieren estados unidos donde
sus opiniones son las censuradas cuando
no están alineadas con las de ellos el
presidente reagan dijo que la libertad
no está nunca a una generación de la
extinción y debe ser que se debe luchar
por ella y es una lucha que solamente mi
padre puede ganar mi padre se lanzó no
porque necesitará el trabajo sino porque
sabía que las personas trabajadores de
este país estaban quedando atrás y los
medios se rieron de estas personas que
ignoraron las banderas de champ y las
gorras
las banderas y los llamados líderes
estaban arrodillados entre chinas
dándole dinero eran y pensaban cómo iban
a ser recibidos por las élites de parís
se preocupaban más por eso de cómo
vivían las personas en pittsburgh
nosotros perdimos amigos pero eso nos
impulsa a luchar más duro y él juró que
cada estadounidense en cada estado y
ciudad que iba a hacer que estados
unidos fuera grande de nuevo y después
comenzó el gran regreso estadounidense
se acabaron las regulaciones y los
impuestos llegamos a una economía a unas
alturas nunca antes vista el desempleo
llegó a su punto más bajo especialmente
para los afroamericanos para los
hispanos para las mujeres los tratos
comerciales fueron renegociados las
mujeres los derechos y millones de
estadounidenses regresaron miles de
dólares regresaron a estados unidos
nuevamente eeuu se hizo la envidia del
mundo
y con esa fortaleza llegó el
apalancamiento el presidente pidió que
los aliados pagaran su parte justa por
la defensa del mundo occidental
reconstruyó las fuerzas militares subió
los sueldos para los hombres y mujeres
en uniforme expandió el presupuesto a
700 mil millones de dólares y ya no
éramos débiles ante los ojos del enemigo
y acabamos con los mayores sonrisas del
planeta
este es el día que en eeuu
juro nunca ser tratado por el enemigo al
bagdadí solimán y muertos
una y otra vez tema tras tema la
economía el muro la los recortes
fiscales los jueces de la corte suprema
right train llevar la embajada a
jerusalén la paz de medio oriente se
están acabando las guerras promesas
hechas y promesas
primera vez se mantuvieron la mayoría de
los políticos pasan la mayoría de su
tiempo en bici y no cumplen con nada por
ejemplo
joe biden es un político que ha estado
en el gobierno durante 47 años y es un
político de carrera que nunca que no
sabe nada sobre el trabajador
estadounidense o sobre los negocios del
país el motor que empuja la mayor
economía que el mundo de jamás haya
visto el mismo político que
estamos bastado sujeto a la china
comunista que ha pasado años huyendo
terry me aún también
joe biden ha permitido aumentar sus
impuestos en 4 billones de dólares la
gran mayoría del país verá aumentar la
dra como aumentan sus impuestos y le
daría amnistía y salud a todos los
inmigrantes ilegales en bailén han
jurado de financiar a la policía y
acabar con su querido segunda enmienda
en mi padre por el otro lado dio los
mayores recortes de impuestos y saben
que si no tenemos fronteras no existe un
país y siempre va a apoyar a la policía
ya las fuerzas y respetar el derecho de
portar y guardar armas
todos los días en su lucha por los
hombres y mujeres olvidados del país
aquellos que representan al espíritu
estadounidense que es como nada en el
mundo
el construyó la represa hoover y bajo
martín
a marte
ser visto en los ojos de cada niño
cuando tomen su primera respiración el
mejor país que el mundo haya conocido en
el país que derrotó el comunismo y el
fascismo y que va también a derrotar
las visiones radicales de la izquierda
radical
en la cita de reagan acaba con esta
advertencia un día podemos pasar nuestro
tiempo diciendo a nuestros niños como
era en eeuu con donde los hombres y las
mujeres eran libres por presidentes en
la libertad nunca es una cosa del pasado
por eso está eso es lo que representa un
voto porción es un voto por el sueño
estadounidense por el espíritu y por la
bandera de este país
por el oficial de policía que ha sido
atacado en castigado y cuyo trabajo
quieren extinguir
mi padre luchará por ustedes para todas
las religiones a todas las personas de
fe en nueve leyes fue boris muchas
libertades quieren ser acabadas mi padre
luchará por ustedes aquellos que no
tienen voz aquellos que han sido
censurados cancelados
mi padre luchará por ustedes nuestros
campesinos y granjeros que trabajan para
mantener nuestros platos llenos
mi padre luchará por ustedes a cada
madre y padre a cada veterano a nuestros
de mineros y para los trabajadores
estadounidenses
mi padre luchará por ustedes y para cada
estadounidense orgulloso que cree que el
azul el blanco el rojo
mi padre continuará luchando por ustedes
y primero quisiera hablarles
directamente a mi padre
extraño trabajar a tu lado cada día pero
me siento muy orgulloso de estar en la
línea de frente de esa lucha me siento
orgulloso de lo que haces por este país
me siento orgulloso de mostrarle a mis
hijos lo que hace su abuelo y me siento
orgulloso de
ver como nunca te detienes como sigues
adelante como sigues luchando porque es
correcto estás haciendo que eeuu sea
fuerte de nuevo estás haciendo que eeuu
se aseguró de nuevo estás haciendo que
el país sea orgulloso de nuevo y si
juntos con los hombres y mujeres
olvidados que finalmente ya no son
olvidados estás haciendo a eeuu grande
de nuevo padre
vamos por otros cuatro años te quiero
mucho y que dios te bendiga y que dios
bendiga a los eeuu de américa